hi hola hey hello so now that we got
that wonderful reading over with I need
your help yes even you that person gives
just listen to this video ends you can
get on top of my face yeah okay I'm
participating in this awesome project
with GE and howcast it's called the
ecomagination video challenge with a
bunch of other youtubers here on YouTube
I need you guys to leave me as many
comments as possible with suggestions of
things to do oh I'm so glad you asked
I'm looking for fun ways to go green or
get other people acting in ways that are
good for the environment so get your
little typing fingers ready for the
course of the next few days I'm also
going to be responding back to a lot of
your suggestions on things to do to help
the environment like what should i do we
need your help you'll need a plan to me
should I starting up at farm should I
fit in a kickback family I really don't
know I have a feeling that you guys are
gonna come up with some really good
ideas and I can't wait to be them GE
really wants to inspire you to tag your
green which basically means using the
internet to get involved and sharing
eco-friendly ideas I really want to get
as many people as possible involved so
be sure to tag your green upload a video
response suggestion or even just a video
of you doing something environmentally
friendly I'm also really excited because
this event is also for charity I'm sure
many of you have probably heard about
charity water but if you haven't they
are an amazing organization that burns
clean water to developing nations our
goal is to get over 10 million views
across all of our videos to raise
awareness for this important cause okay
so are you guys ready because if you're
still watching this far you shouldn't be
watching me well because you should be
down there commenting and I'll be coming
back so I look forward to seeing all of
your comments and suggestions and I
can't wait to see which comment is gonna
win okay thanks i'll see you guys in the
next video
Oh